Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today, we're taking a look at Okteto. It
is a Kubernetes development platform to empower your
developers to innovate faster on cloud native application.
Now before we move into that, there is
a little bit of housekeeping.
If you are not already subscribed to the
YouTube channel, please do so now. Remember to
click the bell, and this will get you
notifications for all new episodes of Rawkode live
as we explore the vast cloud native landscape
together.
Also, if you're not watching live or you
just to chat, we do have a very
active Discord server. We have a few hundred
people in there now talking all things cloud
native, Kubernetes, and everything in between. So feel
free to jump in there, say hello, and
I look forward to seeing you.
Now in order to take a look at
Okteto today, I am joined by founder and
CEO, Ramiro. Hello, Ramiro. How are you today?
Hey, David. It's good good being here. Thanks
thanks for the invite. Good good seeing you.
Yeah. Thank you very much for joining us.
This
is a request from a member in our
Discord community who was like, I really wanna
see a Rawkode live
on
on Okteto. And I was like, alright. Let's
make this happen. And there we go. And
here we are today, hopefully showing everybody what's
happening.
I do have a comment which does have
me slightly worried that people suggest that I
was potentially muted
during my
start. I hope not.
But it's the same waffle that I say
every time, so you've heard it before. Hopefully.
Is it you that's muted or me that's
muted?
I don't know. We'll we'll just move forward.
If I was muted, I'm sorry, Russell. Hopefully,
you can hear me now.
I'll look into that very future.
So why don't you give us the the
all about Ramiro? You wanna tell us about
oh. We're getting a no voice or screen
from Sam.
Oh.
It looks okay on my end. I will,
however, check.
But while we do that, do you wanna
tell us a little bit about your mural?
Oh, no. Russell says it was his laptop.
You all have given me the fear today.
That's what's happening.
Just putting us putting us in the spotlight.
Yeah. I've got the video. I'm now watching
my own show well, streaming on my own
show and feel like a bit of a
dafti, but
from what I can tell,
it looks okay. Sorry. Sorry about that, Ramiro.
Yeah. No worries. Could you tell us a
little bit about yourself, please? And then we'll
talk about Okteto after that.
Yeah. That sounds sounds good. Well, my name
is Ramiro. I was originally born in Mexico.
I grew up in in Guadalajara.
And right after school I went school there
for for computer science.
Right after that, I I moved to US.
I've been living in The US for about,
oof, eleven, twelve years now. First in Seattle.
I I used to work at a at
Microsoft there. I was part of the Azure
team or
as it was called back then back then
dot net services something.
But ever since then, I've I've been working
on dev tools, which was one of the
one of the luckiest things for me was
I ended up right after school working for
Azure,
building, you know, services and dev tools.
From there, moved to Bay Area, joined a
startup that a couple of my friends started,
Elastic Box, a few years ago, kind of
the DevOps puppet space. And since then, I've
been working on on different companies and all
around dev tools. I work in Elasticbox.
I work for Atlassian where was part of
the team that was building hip chats and
a bunch of other internal things.
And then about
two and a half years ago, three years,
I decided to quit my job.
Two of my closest friends, Pablo and Ramon,
who were working at Docker and
Gmail at the time,
we always had to quit and sort of
Ted on just because we were we kept
seeing this all these problems around, you know,
companies building
teams building microservices
on containers, on Kubernetes, and we kept seeing
that they were having all these awful problems
around not being very effective and a ton
of friction.
And that's how we started Okteto. It was
first an open source project and slowly
kinda
started to take a life of its own,
and we ended up with a company. Now
we're, like, busy funded and and building this
this cool platform.
Awesome. That's a really great backstory.
There's something really great about building developer tooling.
Found I've always been myself slightly,
you know, pulled towards that. I don't know
if it's a sector or an industry or
just tooling in general, but
it's very rewarding to empower and make developers
more efficient and happier and just
get rid of all that toil and pain
from developing applications.
Really
good thing to be working on. So Oh,
no. %.
That's always been
every team I joined
unintentionally,
I always been that developer who's always like,
trying to improve. Like, I remember I joined
this team with with I won't name them,
but I joined the team and it was
like, what? There's there was like, at that
point, no CI,
no process. So I was I was spending
a lot of nights kind of for fun,
like, setting up, you know, a CI server,
validation for pull request. It was always about
I
just I just enjoyed kinda, building these these
tools to make make my team more effective,
have them struggle less, and
I don't know. It it comes with my
nature. I've never been able to avoid it.
Even even when I at some point, I
was like, I'm done with dev tools. I
was gonna join Atlassian and went to this
chat product,
and I ended up building dev tools behind
the scenes for my team. So I I
do like it. I think I think as
you said, there's there's something really cool about
being able to empower developers and and really
help.
You know, like, good tools really multiply
a team's effort.
That is something I've seen. Yeah. And that
is something that we're trying to to replicate
with Okteto is is just make people as
as efficient
as they can because I I do believe
that, you know, we can build really cool
stuff, and and developers have passion to build
and change the world. So giving them tools
to make their lives a little bit easier
so they can focus on their goals and
not on this low level
kinda, like, infra
deployment kinda issues,
it's super rewarding.
Yeah. Definitely. I I I think I'm the
exact same kind of developer as you. Every
team I've went to is, like, I just
love finding points of friction and trying to
automate them away or provide tooling to get
rid of them and stuff like that. So
you can tell just by that, I'm very
excited about looking at something that, you know,
to the quote from your website, I think
it's great. Empower developers to innovate and deliver
cloud native applications faster.
I would like to do that personally, so
I'm looking forward to our demo today.
Okay. Let's
do you wanna if I ask you what
Okteto is, do you wanna talk about that,
or do you wanna dive straight in? Will
we do both? Let's go. Let's dive straight
in. I think the best the best way
to tell you what Okteto is is by
by you seeing
what we can do, and and we can
always just stop in the middle. And if
anybody has questions, we can ask them answer
them as we go, I think. Of course.
Yeah. Definitely, if you are watching just now
and you want to ask any questions, drop
them straight into the YouTube chat. We will
do our best to tackle them as we
go through our little demo today.
This is Okteto.com,
the homepage. There's loads of nice cool things
here for you to flex through, but we
are gonna dive straight into the documentation for
today.
We will be working through the quick start
guide, taking a few little segues as we
go to look at some of the features
that Okteto provides to you.
So
to get started, I am going to register
for Okteto cloud.
Log in with GitHub.
Oh, it popped up over here. That's always
fun.
There we go.
Okay. Ramiro, it is now yours your chance
to shine. What am I looking at, and
what is Okteto?
Right. So that what you're looking at is
is what we call the developer dashboard.
When you log in to Okteto, Okteto is
a
platform that gives you self-service access to
Kubernetes.
One of the first things that we wanted
to kinda, like,
build was this management layer on top of
Kubernetes to automate all the things
that developers need to do to work. So
when you log in, the first thing that
happened is that we already created
a namespace for you, applied a bunch of,
like, network policies and and other types of
policies.
We create an account for you,
and we put you in a quota. So
at this at this point,
you are ready to start. You could download
your credentials. You can directly deploy your dev
environment
on Okteto.
And if you follow the the getting inside
of the guide, that is what's gonna happen.
And as you deploy applications, you will see
that this dashboard starts to fill in with
your apps, your logs, these types of things.
The idea here is that for, you know,
80% of your tasks, you're not gonna have
to go back to the terminal. You could
just see what's going on with your applications
and your dev environments right on this dashboard.
Okay. That sounds cool. So we have to
get something deployed then. Right?
Mhmm. I know it's kind of Yeah. That's
how the whole thing starts. The first thing
you do is you deploy your dev environment.
We have a bunch of samples, or you
can deploy from your own GitHub account.
Okay. Let's deploy the Okteto movies application.
No? Yes. That's our sample. So if you
click on the other tab on the get
get URL tab
on the right Yep. That'll give you the
the shortcuts to the sample.
Of course. There we go. That's nice.
Removing friction already. I like that.
Now I should read the docs. I was
just gonna click the big deploy button. Go
ahead and deploy. I I know we're all
we're all developers. We like to go faster
things, so deploy. Yeah. I get myself in
trouble whenever I do that. I mean, I
don't need the docs. No. No. We'll just
click this button. We'll do this. We'll oh,
it's none of nothing works. Sorry. That's that's
and, honestly, that's what we're trying to accomplish
here is you should be able to use
deploy without, like, looking anywhere else. And then
when you get stuck, you'll find the docs.
That's that's how I like my tools. Oh,
definitely. I couldn't agree more. So let me
try and speculate at what I think is
happening here, and I guess maybe you can
correct me if I'm wrong. But looks to
me like it's CloneDeR repository. Mean, it's telling
me it's CloneDeR repository.
That that is a given. We've got an
Okteto build, which looks very similar to just
a container image build of some kind with
a tag and a directory that it's building.
I'm assuming it's found a Dockerfile and the
movies directory is built an image, and it
is just gonna deploy that to this Kubernetes
cluster that you have provided.
Is that close?
Yeah. Yeah. That that's pretty close. So when
when you create a when you create an
account on Okteto, some of the other things
you have access to besides a q a
cube cluster is that you also have access
to a remote build service.
It's a it's a service we're running on
Okteto cloud. It's powered by BuildKit with some
changes we made on top of that, and
also a container registry. And the idea is
kinda the same, reducing friction. You don't have
to think about building the image. You don't
have to think about where you're gonna push
it. Okteto takes care of all of those
things. If you look in that repo, you
see there's an Okteto pipeline file.
That is a file that you can use
to tell Okteto how to build and deploy
your application.
This case, you'll see we're building. You use
Okteto build to use the Okteto build service,
and then just a typical Helm upgrade. In
this case, we are using the Git commit
to ensure that we have a unique image.
And this is one of the patterns you
see in our samples. It's the idea that
you deploy, it self contain,
Okteto builds all the artifacts you need. And
because you have a shared registry and a
shared build service, you'll see that a lot
of these things are way faster than local
because now you're gonna take advantage of the
fact that it's running on the cloud.
And because it's a shared service, you and
your team are gonna kinda share, like, base
layers of your containers, certain caches, and things
like that to make your life easier. You
click deploy,
and it builds everything for you.
Okay. Cool.
What are the history lines? I'm curious.
That That's that's interesting. That's part
of Okteto. Besides Okteto Cloud, and and if
you walk through the through the demo, you'll
see it. There's a CLI
that allows you to develop directly on the
cluster, and that's what the Okteto Jaml is.
It's a command that you run locally.
It will synchronize your code, keep your code
hot loaded with your container so that dev
part of the pipeline
is just a way for you to give
your team a hint of how to use
Okteto. If you go back to the UI,
you'll see there's a button that looks that
says develop.
It's that play button on the on the
left.
If you click on it, you'll see that
the the hint pops up.
So just, yeah, start development? Uh-huh. Yeah. It's
still one of them.
Okay.
Do you want me to correct that now,
or do you wanna cover anything else on
this screen? At least, like, the other things
you see in that screen is when you
deploy an application, Okteto integrates with cert manager
to create, like, SSL certificates for your apps,
and it's gonna give you a public endpoint.
So, again, you don't have to worry about
it. The whole idea is you deploy and
you see your app. This is a live
link that when you redeploy, it will get
updated with your code,
and it's something you can share
with with anybody. It it works on the
Internet.
And, yep, we have this application. It's a
multi service app used to kinda showcase where
how Okteto works.
There's a bit of a bug in that
app that will
as part of the of the getting started,
we'll show you how to fix. Is that
why I can't watch the equalizer too? Because
I was getting quite excited there. Are we
gonna fix it?
Okay.
That's that's that's really cool. I love And
the other thing is if you click on
the components
of your application, you see the states and
you see the logs live from the pod.
So you don't have to go and run
Kubectl logs, find the name of the pod,
and all those things. You can get it
directly from here. If you if you were
to have more than one container, you can
filter by container.
If you were to have more than one
pods, you can also filter by pods. And,
again, it's just about putting the information that
developers need
on a dashboard in front of of them
so they don't have to go digging for
these things as they are writing their code.
Nice. I like it.
You also mentioned I could yeah. There we
go. I can download the actual KubeConfig if
I want, and I can just work with
my development cluster directly.
Exactly.
Pretty flexible right at the bat. Okay. That
is that is part of of of our
vision there is, you know, dev developers use
a lot of tools. Every developer has their
own workflow.
So for us, it's important to be able
to integrate with
everything else on the on the cloud native
space. Like, you can download the credentials and
you can use QCTL,
customize
anything else you want, helm charts.
Just we just released an integration with Docker
Compose. And and the idea is
we want to empower and extend the developer's
workflow, but we don't wanna force them in
a very specific path of, like, you have
to rewrite your applications to have this or
that shape.
So we're trying hard to to do that
and and giving you access to the Kubernetes
namespace. It's a it's an important part of
that.
Awesome.
So you said a few minutes ago then
that I should click on the start development
on one of these services. Is is that
still where you wanna go, or should I
go back to my docs and stop making
up?
Go back to the go back to the
docs and and let's follow those.
Alright.
Yes. So we've done this. So we took
a look at the application. It looks great.
I have the ability to install the Okteto
CLI.
Do you want me to do that?
Yep.
Alright.
Okteto CLI gives you the kinda like the
computer side like, the terminal side aspect of
this.
Run Okteto login to connect
or main space.
Yes,
please.
Yes. And
I am logged in. Painless.
Oh, yeah.
So that
has created a context and my local KubeConfig.
So it's not active just yet, I think.
Was that gonna be my other
Yeah. Not yet. So run Okteto run Okteto
namespace
first.
And then one of the things we do
here, and that's why that command didn't work,
is that Okteto gives you access to a
namespace, not the full cluster. And and the
idea behind this is that as a developer,
we want you not to care about infrastructure.
We just want you to care about your
application.
So we found, like, the namespace context. The
namespace
abstraction is is a good one for that.
So you just do, like, get pods. Uh-huh.
And then you have, you know, admin as
your namespace. You can deploy whatever you want
there. We apply some policies to make this,
you know, so you can play well with
everybody else who's using that that shared infrastructure,
but you should be able to just run
your application and anything there.
Cool. Awesome.
Okay. So we've run namespace. We've got our
we've now put down that config with dedicated
against the service.
I can now clone the movies repository.
So
is this is this
already a kind of a fork and they're
getting started guys? Like, there are two different
ways to get started. Like, assuming if I
clone this and run these commands locally, I
can just develop against the cluster. Is that
different? Mhmm. Maybe I'm making this up now,
but if what happens if I click to
start development? Because my my interest is definitely
peaked now.
Click on it. That button is is gonna
show you the the same instructions that the
getting started will will show you. Okay. It's
a it's a a way to tell people,
hey. This is how you use Okteto.
Because what what happens with Okteto and one
of the things that we're doing that really
sets us apart
is the our our flow is you develop
you deploy your dev environment on on this
cluster, so you have an application that's functional.
And now you use the CLI to start
developing.
In this case, this example shows you how
to develop an API. So you just run
Okteto up,
and that will
transform this application into what we call
dev
your dev environment.
Yeah. That error was just because I was
using a I already had my config set
to a relative path, which was never never
gonna work. So
that should be fixed now, hopefully.
Yeah. Yeah. We have to do a lot
of things on the CLI to to enable
those sort of things. It's it's not it's
tricky.
So what's happening now is you you earlier
on the on the stream, you showed this
Okteto dot JAML file. So what's happening now
is that Okteto is
using the information on that JAML to transform
the existing API deployment into your dev environment.
And transforming means everything from
relaunching it with a different image. If you
have a a special container with your dev
tools,
getting all your all your code, synchronizing your
file,
and forwarding some ports. At this point,
Okteto open a terminal for you, and you
are on the dev container.
Is that what I I did see my
prompt change,
and then I rang it Right. That's what
it changed then. And if you look at
the at the context and namespace, it's telling
you where you are. So for instance, just
dump the environment.
And you see one of the one of
the very cool things about this model is
that you have the same configuration that your
application has. So you have access to the
same environment variables.
This is running with the same identity that
your application is running. So as you write
code,
it's gonna save you that step of writing
your code locally,
then push it to Kubernetes, and then test
it there. And instead, you directly, you know,
write your code on your ID.
Okteto will synchronize that to this dev container.
You can then just run your process there
and
test directly in your cluster so that you
know that your application works with all the
other pieces that are still there, but they
are still in what we call production mode,
which is the same way that your application
is defined.
This is just a normal shell terminal. So
if you run JARN install and JARN start,
you can just get the the API started
again.
Alright. I think it's Well, if you go
back to the actually, let's do something. Stop
stop that process. Do a control c,
and go back go back to the browser
and and
hit the application.
Okay.
So we wanna hit the front end. We
wanna click on this link.
K. You see that now that the API
is not the application is not loading. That's
because the API is not running. So now
go to your dev container and use to
start the
but do join dev instead of join start.
Please join dev. Nope. It's
open open your ID or
or yeah. Or that.
Beam might not be there, and that's on
purpose because we want you to use your
ID.
Oh, Jarmstar. It was Jarmstar.
There we go. So that will start, in
this case, the application with NodeMode so so
that it will hot reload as you make
changes. So if you go to your ID
and make a change on the
on the API code, Okteto will synchronize the
code, your process will hot reload,
and you're gonna be able to see the
changes in real time.
So modify the code locally,
and it's gonna be propagated to my dev
container, which is running on a Kubernetes cluster
on Okteto.
Okay. So for instance, the bug I was
telling you about is if you go to
the API and go to the go to
the main file there, I think is the
server JS,
and then just navigate through the code and
find the call to API
watching,
which is the next block. Yep.
So on line 43,
this application has a bug. I'm gonna
give you give it away, which is there.
It's calling the movies collection instead of the
watching collection. So before you make any changes,
go to the browser and and reload your
application
to kinda get it get our baseline. So
you will see that both lists, movies and
continue watching, are the same list and they
should not be. One should be the movies
available,
the other should be the movies that Cindy
is watching.
And Cindy is our kinda, like, our our
persona, our default user.
That's a funny story, but I'll save that
for later.
Okay. So what Okay. What what we're just
testing is if I update this to be
the watching collection and hit save as we
go back Uh-huh.
We should see that change happen
at our front end of our application.
Exactly. So just go back to the go
back to the front to the browser and
reload.
Look at that. And there it is. What
am I watching? And if you go through
your terminal, you'll see that
Node one detected a file chain, reloaded. And
the cool thing about this is that you're
testing your changes without having to rebuild your
containers
and having to run, you know, a local
mini cube or any of those things. It's
just about you focusing on your code, building
your application,
and Okteto takes care of all the other
things underneath.
Very cool. I I like that. How
is it syncing the changes from my local
directory?
Is that part of the Okteto app?
Exactly. The Okteto up is doing
that's, like, three three stages. The first one
is it's gonna find the deployment.
And what do you open Okteto.Jamin
to? Can explain the the different things it's
doing or maybe this.
This one or the pipeline? No. Exact. So
the first thing you have is name.
That is what's telling
Okteto which deployment you're gonna target to turn
into their environment.
In this case, it's a deployment called API.
You could also specify a label, selector, and
more complex things.
So the first thing that happens is Okteto
up will find
will go
to the cluster and find a deployment named
API.
Then
we have a a mutation webhook that will
apply certain overrides. In this case, it's just
a starting command, but you could override environment
variables, inject more files,
have extra secrets, like, change your image, anything
you need to develop.
So that's the second thing it does. It's
redeploys your your pot,
applies this dev overrides,
and as it boots up,
then it's gonna do two more things. One
is
it's gonna start as a synchronization
process
on your local machine,
and it's gonna inject another synchronization service on
your container. We use an open source project
for this called SyncThing,
and that is what keeps
the files
in sync both ways. If you modify a
file on your local machine,
it will be synchronized to the container.
If you change a file on the container,
it will sync be synchronized back into your
local machine.
If you do like a PSOX on either
your local machine or the container, you will
see these processes running.
Well, I mean, I I need to know
to this.
Yes.
So that's an the source directory of the
API package dot JSON.
So
look at that.
There is. That's pretty cool.
So that one's pretty useful for instance when
you do a join install because then it
synchronize your log file.
And there's a special file there called dot
s t ignore where you can configure if
you don't want things to be changed. Like,
if you if you want certain files, like,
you don't want your note modules to be
synchronized.
You don't want your dot kit to be
synchronized, and you can add whatever you need
there. That's, like, super flexible.
We create a default based on the on
the language of your of your repo Mhmm.
But you can add whatever you want depending
on your application. You know, 10 files,
static assets you you only want on your
container or, you know, test results you only
want locally, things like that.
Cool.
Okay. That makes sense. I I understand that.
So you said I I can run
a PS locally or NS over And
and there's our same thing processes here. And
again, I guess I just do that locally.
I'll see the same thing. So there can
be some of feature. And there's also the
the update remote, we also start an SSH
server. So this time that you're seeing
is actually going over a mix of QCTL
port forward and an SSH tunnel
so that you can also forward
any port you want from local to remote
or vice versa.
So for instance, right now, you see that
Okteto YAML is forwarding port eighty eighty. You
could go to local host eighty eighty, and
you're gonna hit the the API.
What's more fun is that you can also
use that to forward the port of your
debugger,
and then you can do things like debug
remotely.
I'm sorry. When should I
run that? Am I working? The process first.
Alright. Okay.
Okay. So sorry. What was the next step?
I got confused there. I got too excited
to know what's going on. Go go back
to the I think where the way you
run go back to the Versus Code. I
think that's where we're running the or no.
It's here, actually. No. Just do the darn
star there. Yeah. Oh, yeah. I I I
turned that off. Okay. So we run you
on start again. Uh-huh. And then open a
local terminal.
Okay. That's that's cool. Okay. I like that.
I think you have to do slash API
and slash health or something. But, yeah, that
that enables a little really cool scenarios because
you can do forward and reverse
proxy tunnels.
So you can do, for instance, if you
have a database running on Kubernetes, you could
have it piped through Okteto, so you can
still run your local I don't know, like
the MongoDB IDE.
Or if you want to run debugger,
like this project comes configured to use debugger.
So you could start the node process on
a debugger, and then Versus Code debug and
do step by step debugging on the ID
with a process that's running on the container.
And and all of this goes back to
same idea of
we wanna make it easy for developers to
develop the same way they do locally, but
expand that to, like, an entire
namespace or an entire cluster in in certain
scenarios.
And,
yeah, and one cool thing about the the
Okteto CLI is that today, you're using it
with Okteto cloud,
but, actually, the CLI works with any Kubernetes
cluster. If you have your own,
if you have mini cube, k three s,
any of those, it just works. As long
as it's Kubernetes compatible
and you have a cube config, it will
just use that. So it's something that you
can use even if you don't wanna use
the rest of the of the platform, even
if you don't wanna use the cloud
or we also have a self hosted version
of Okteto cloud that you can install on
any cluster. If you don't wanna use those
things, you can still benefit from this flow
of dev container, sync your code, hover load
super fast. So that's a that's something that
a lot of our users really, really like
as they build things in MinIQ, in p
three s, or anywhere else.
I personally believe that people should not be
running clusters and use, a remote thing, but
different developers have different workflows. And, you know,
we all work with what works for us.
Okay. I just wanna make sure I understood
that right. I can run Okteto up with
a cube config pointed to my own cluster,
and I get all of the same ability
to develop my application and Versus code and
do the debugging if I want with the
shared ports and sync thing.
But I I won't get any of
this, the UI. Right? But I I I
Exactly. You don't want the UI. You don't
get the build service.
You don't get the automatic
ingress creation.
All those things is what the platform gives
you. Well, the core dev experience of
dev environment on Kubernetes, sync my code, port
forwards,
terminal to the container, all that works on
any Kubernetes cluster.
Okay. But
I don't use the UI.
I haven't given you any credit card details.
I'm assuming there's a a nice flexible free
tier there for anyone to sign up and
use. But what what you're using right now
is the free tier.
That one will let you create up to,
I think, three namespaces,
and you can run up to 10 parts
per namespace. So it's a it's pretty flexible.
And, yeah, here is it's enough for you
to build an application.
And and what else it has?
You have us to a build service, to
the registry. There's also, like, secrets you can
create if you want to have a,
like, m bars overwritten during deployment time. And
then
the there's a pay tier, which gives you
more CPU, more memory, and more pods in
case you have a a bigger application that
doesn't fit on on this tier.
It's that that free tier, I think, will
be great for many small teams or even
solo developers. So they just don't really want
to worry about any of this stuff, and
they can get started super quick. So That
is that is the yeah. That is the
idea with with when we were building
everything has started with the open source project.
And as we show that to people, the
CLI,
one of the first things that a lot
of our friends told us was,
this is great, but I don't wanna run
a cluster. I don't wanna run a dev
cluster. Or someone who was, like, in IT
was, I don't wanna give my dev team
a dev cluster because they're gonna keep, you
know, harassing me with, like, tickets and things
to do. And that's where the idea to
build this came to us. It was like,
okay. Maybe we can build this other component
to give you self-service access to a cluster,
apply all these policies so it can be
shared among a team
so I can, like, override your changes and
things like that. And that's how this other
product came to be.
And another thing also is that we also
have a self hosted version of Okteto Cloud.
So if you have your own cluster,
it's only a home install, and it's also
it's free for teams of up to three
developers.
So for small teams who have their own
clusters, you can just get the same experience
you saw today
on
on your own cluster, which is it's also
useful if if you need to connect to
VPCs or running a specialized hardware.
Yep. We have a lot of users that
run Okteto on, like, clusters with GPUs, and
then they do, like they run their machine
learn machine learning models
through this kinda, like, remote terminal. And it's
kinda a very cool
very cool way to to mix Kubernetes and,
you know, the power of having the cloud
with, like, all the CPUs
and still get this really fast dev cycle.
Awesome.
Alright. We kinda went on a little
tour there. Let's jump back to our docs.
Let's see if it seems there's anything that
we've missed, and then we can kinda take
a look at maybe some of those other
features that Okteto brings to the table. So
we did do the Okteto up. There's the
information about the fail synchronization,
the container ports.
We did look at the environment variables. We've
seen all of that stuff being done. We
did do this. I think we well done.
You went through the the getting started guide
without even having to reference it. That's pretty
sweet.
Alright. I have done this demo once or
twice before. Maybe. Alright.
Well, let's pick a couple of more things
from this left hand sidebar that you think
might be interesting to to talk about. And
then I know that you've got
another demo that you would like to do
for us so we can take a look
at that after that.
Right. Well, one thing that you already mentioned
is the the Kubernetes credentials feature,
is you can download the the kube config
through a UI or through a command line,
and that enables you to use Okteto with
pretty much any
whatever your favorite dev tool is.
Anything that doesn't require you to have access
to the full cluster, so anything that works
a namespace level will work with Okteto. So
Lens,
k nine's,
customized helm,
QCTL,
any of these things.
We've partnered with companies like
Chaos Native, Litmus Chaos, works in Okteto. You
can run your case experiments there. Things like
that. That's one that's one thing that's really
cool.
The other is the the namespaces feature,
which is, like, you can create more than
one namespace.
You can do it directly from the UI.
There's a button there, new namespace, and you
just create more namespaces.
What I like about that is that Okteto
manages everything, the namespace creation,
the
permissions, all those things are just for you.
But you can always share namespaces with anybody
else.
One of the cool things about training spaces
is that
right now, you did Okteto up on the
API, but you can actually do Okteto up
on any service. I you could share your
namespace with me.
I can then go to Okteto up on
the front end,
and then we can be working together,
maybe working on new API or a new
version of the application
without me having to wait for you to
be done and send me a PR,
and they have to start the thing myself.
So even if it was the sharing namespaces
enables a really cool flow. Or even if
you just want, hey. I need help. Here.
Let me share my namespace,
and then you can see the logs of
my pods. You can see what I deployed.
It's a it's a really interesting way to
especially for teams that are remote Yeah. And
where it might be hard to get someone
to kinda, hey. Come over to my desk
and see what's going on. It's a it's
a simple way to to kinda get that
started. So that's that's something that I I
use a lot personally, and I I like
it I like it as a as a
way to, you know, make my team I
am going back to the same theme of
making the team more efficient. That's something that's
really cool.
Do you develop Okteto on Okteto?
Yes. We do. Yeah. We
use it for for everything. Like,
it's as and it's getting back to what
you were saying. One of the one of
the best things for me about building dev
tools
is that I'm a developer.
So it's something that you're building for yourself.
Like, I use all those features. Like, every
each of these features came either because we
had a need
or someone someone from our community, hey. I
wanna do this other thing.
And and that's a really cool way. And
I I don't know about other
spaces, but on DevTools, it's a really cool
thing that I know, hey. This is something
useful because I would use it. And if
this is the beginning, that helps a lot
to kinda keep you keep you focused and
motivated on on those things. Yeah. I I
think that's just great advice to get to
anyone that's thinking of starting a a company
or building a product. Like, if you're solving
a problem that you have, there's a good
chance that, a, you're gonna be invested in
it emotionally as well and continue to work
on it even when things get tough. But
you're also solving a problem that, you know,
exists and hopefully other people have. And I
think, yeah, just working in that space, working
it's really difficult to say, I wanna go
fix this problem with this person over here
if you don't have that problem. So, yeah,
a really good thing. Yeah. It's definitely
and you you're right on motivation. It and
it's so much
easier when a developer comes to me and
say, hey. I'm trying to deploy this Go
app, and I have this issue. Like, oh,
yeah. Right. Let me help you, and we'll
debug it together. And, yeah, you're right. We're
missing this feature, and then we'll go and
implement that. And then we'll go back to
this developer and show him the feature and
and should be very excited.
It's a it's a really nice flow that
that I like a lot. So it's it's
part of why why I'm on this business.
Definitely.
Another cool thing, if you wanna take a
dive, is go into the deploy methods
on the left. Yep.
Mhmm.
So that's that's that's something. And then go
on git.
Yep.
So one one thing we didn't cover and
that's quite
powerful is that Okteto allows you to deploy
when you click deploy, you can deploy an
application
from a Git repo, which you already showed.
What you can also deploy, we have a
catalog of applications
that's powered by Helm, so you can deploy
one click deploy applications from Helm
or just from your terminal.
When you deploy it from Git, though,
you have access to a lot of other
features to customize your deployment. Like, if you
could click on Okteto pipeline,
this is it's kinda similar to the way
CICD works where you can define a script
on how to deploy your application,
and, you know, there's a lot of things
there.
If you don't have a good pipeline file,
Okteto will try to guess what your repo
looks like and deploy it. So if you
have a ham chart, it will do a
ham install.
If you have a k h dot JAML
file, it will do kubectl apply.
If you have a Docker Compose file, it
will do Okteto stacks.
And if it can't figure it out, it'll
tell you, hey. I don't know what to
do. But you can always add this kinda,
like, magic file, Okteto dash pipeline,
and you have full control.
Some of our users do things like provision
third party services, provision cloud services if they
need,
all the way to, you know, like like
movies, which builds and deploy the app. So
that's a really cool thing where it opens
the door to more complex deployments. You know,
applications have different shapes,
and sometimes you need to provision other resources.
So that is a cool way where you
can extend Okteto to do other things.
Nice. That was one of the things that
actually,
you know, had popped into my head as
we were playing with the movies example. I
was like, oh, okay. There's a, like, fatal
pipeline that can defend all these steps. And
then when you showed me the the dev
one, in my head, I was like, well,
it looks and feels like a Docker Compose
file, but it's not. But, I mean, I
could just use a Docker Compose file,
which, you know, hopefully Teams and and stuff
like that have been using it for a
couple of years now. They're not losing that
configuration. It's it's not going anywhere. They still
have the flexibility to use that and deploy
it using Intel.
And Yeah. That is that is actually one
feature we just released last week. We kinda
still release it. We haven't made any announcements.
And and thanks for bringing it up. It's
really cool. We took
the team took the compose, which is now
open source Yep. For people who don't know
this,
and we implemented the entire spec to do
a translation from compose to Kubernetes.
Because as you said, a lot of teams
are still using compose for development, and it's
great. It's a really easy way to deploy
your application
and and just kinda describe it and see
it.
And a lot of the peep the teams
that you were seeing on TETO, they didn't
like Helm that much or they were not
as used to Helm than they are to
Compose. So we ended up implementing this this
feature. So if you go back to the
to the to the Okteto UI just just
real quick to show you a quick demo.
Click on deploy
and go to from compose.
And that is a very simple example, but
you see that is an actual compose file.
Mhmm. It's a it's a hello world. You
can put any compose file you want there.
You can get, like, the movies app and
and things, and then just deploy it. And
Okteto will translate from Compose to Kubernetes,
create all the things for you. And our
goal here is that anyone should be able
to if you have a repo with a
Docker Compose on it,
you should be able to click
deploy,
put your repo,
and it would just work.
If it doesn't work, you know, we have
a Slack. Go join the Kubernetes Slack. Go
to the Okteto channel and and talk to
us, and and we'll we'll work on this
together.
Alright. Well, we we did actually get a
comment from Vignesh
who told us to give it a try
with with Docker Compose.
Are we feeling brave? Are you happy for
me to pick a Compose file? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Of course.
One one that I like to demo is
if you if you go
find the Docker movie,
the voting app.
Do you know about that? Do you know
have you seen that demo? Yeah. Couple of
years ago, remember the movie voting app. So
But that is the that is a prototypical,
kinda like Docker Compose demo. So just, you
know, you go to GitHub. How can I
send this to you? Do we have a
chat here? This one here? Well, that one.
Yeah. You got it. Just just copy the
URL. Let's let's see if it works.
Alright. Let's go to URL and go to
Chero. Uh-huh. And just create a new nice
business for for fun.
Just for fun. Okay. Yeah. We will pile
up on things.
Okay. We'll call this voting Rawkode.
I had to apply.
We're gonna do
Go from git. Go from git, and then
just drop in the URL? Uh-huh.
Okay. So
this has no Okteto
pipeline. This is just Nope. A docker compose
dot We don't we don't own the repo.
That's that repo is a
it's part of a docker samples repo, so
nothing there for us.
And just hit deploy?
Uh-huh.
K. We got a clone detected the Docker
Compose,
and it's been an Okteto Stack Deploy.
Okay. We'll see. I'm a little bit nervous.
I haven't been with testing.
Funny one funny thing is that one of
my cofounders and co maintainers, Pablo, he he
used to work for this company called Tudum
that
Docker acquired, and they were actually the ones
that creating the voting app samples. It was
a nice kinda full circle of
my friend working that in Docker, and then
with our company, now we're building this this
compatibility layer.
But that's the core idea is that is
we map the we map the resources to
Kubernetes, you know, with
the idea that as a developer,
for a lot of these things, you don't
care. You just compose good enough. Therefore, you're
composed. It'll work. You can still use all
the other tooling we showed today,
Okteto up, CLI,
all those things.
But with the added benefit that you don't
have to
keep these two different manifests. Right? If you
have a Compose, just use Compose
as you get deeper into Kubernetes
and you start using Helm,
then you can migrate to Helm or other
things. But for a lot of people, Compose
is a really good format, and it just
works for them. So it's it's something that
we're
very excited that even this is open source.
It's it's in the CLI.
So it's something that we're very excited to
to see if people like, and then maybe
it's something we can push
for other other teams or products to also
start using.
Yeah. I don't know if the output here
is, you know
is is it BuildKit? Because it doesn't look
like a standard Docker build, so I'm assuming.
It is it is BuildKit. So we we
fork BuildKit,
and we added some extra code to make
it more multitenant
friendly.
But at the core, it's BuildKit. Like
like every other you know, we build on
top of open source. Yeah. We're building on
top of BuildKit, Container Registry.
We use engine x ingress, cert manager, Kubernetes
itself,
mutation web hooks. And using BuildKit is also
really cool because that allows allowed us to
be compatible with any Dockerfile. Like, you don't
have to do anything special.
You can even take advantage of all the
cool things that
BuildKit gives you, caching
on different front ends, all those things. So
it's a there you go. It's it's getting
there.
Yeah. I I think BuildKit is just one
of the most exciting things we've had in
a while from, like, in a container buildy
docker landscape. It's amazing. It's amazing, and it's
something that I
I don't know what I mean, more people
should be using it. It's really it's really,
really powerful, and it's it's compatible in a
Docker file. And
Yeah. So the cache has experimental flag right
now. Right? I think you you have with
at least with the Docker CLI, you have
to explicitly enable the experimental features to be
able to have to put a a header.
Right? But
definitely something that
I don't know what the plan there is,
but it's something that anyone I highly recommend
looking to it, especially if you're building
if you're building node images, just caching the
node modules saves so much time on your
builds.
Yeah.
Or caching the the other the the binary
the binary the compiled folder on node. Same
thing on Go. It's it's really cool. There
we go. Let's see if it works. I
have all green. There's an endpoint there.
There we go.
Cool. And then I'll go back, and there's
a results service that will show you your
vote.
Hold on. Let me click.
I think I'm gonna vote once.
One per person. But if anybody were to
log in, that's a public endpoint. Anybody can
log in and and see the vote. But
Damn it. My vote went to cats.
I'm gonna hold it back then. Okay. A
cat person, so yes.
Like cats and dogs, to be fair. I
I love all animals. I'm actually surrounded by
I've got chinchillas over here, five of them.
I've got a free free roaming ferret that
lives in my office with Oh, wow. Daggers
in the room.
All animals are welcome in here.
That sounds nice.
Awesome. That
that was a nice little surprise. I had
no idea that we could just throw
Docker compose at that. I mean, I have
so many just like example repositories that I
keep on GitHub with Docker compose files and
and just being able to drop that URL
in here and have a nice visual representation.
I think that's so so important for people.
Like, you know, a lot of people aren't
indoctrinated into Kubernetes sharing containers. They've not been
doing this for four years or five years.
They've been doing it for weeks or months.
And these UIs these
GUIs
are are just there to make that easier
for these people and get the logs out
of it and work with it and browse
the URL without having to worry about put
forwards in that. I love UIs like this
that solve real problems. Yeah.
That is that is for me part like,
super important is is the
ease of use, get you get you going
and,
like, the best thing for me is when
people tell us, hey. We're I'm not even
thinking about, you know, Kubernetes.
It's a great technology. I'm a big fan.
I've been involved for, like, many years now.
But I like it when they become invisible.
You know? It's like, I don't wanna think
of Kubernetes. I wanna think of my application.
We we had a
one day, we're chatting with Kelsey at Hightower,
and I was his advice was like, you
need to make this invisible. Like, People care
about their apps.
Kubernetes is great. It solves huge amount of
problems,
but what we care about is what our
apps can do. So that's what we're trying
to do here is is to speed you
up so that you can get to the
app phase of your work as quickly as
possible and then build forwards
endpoints.
Infrastructure itself
should just be a giving. It would just
be there for you and just change your
code, see the results as fast as possible,
and and be there.
Awesome.
We actually have a a comment from Sangam
who has suggested that you don't even need
Docker installed Yeah. If you have the That's
true. CLI. That's a good point, Sangam. That's
Sangam is our one of our oldest,
dearest members of the community.
Yeah. You're right, Sangam.
With Okteto built,
because the the build service is running on
the cloud,
whether it's on our cloud or if you
install Okteto on your own cluster, then the
builds happen remotely. So you don't have to
run Docker. Like, I I got Mac Mini
and one of the new ones, m ones.
I didn't even install Docker on this machine.
I've been using Okteto build.
We it's compatible with the CLI and because
it uses doc it uses built kit, it
can build anything. So it's a yeah. It's
another small benefit.
You're surprised how many people just mentioned that,
hey. Not having to run so many things
on my local machine
makes them so much happier.
And and, you know, especially if you if
you're using hardware that is not, like, super
powerful, like, you know, not everybody in the
world has, like, a map map and put
all with, like, you know, god knows how
many cores at this point. Like, all people
are working on on more models machines. Yeah.
So being able to offload a lot of
that to a cluster makes their life significantly
better.
Yeah.
I I I I'm already fully
believing in remote
development server approach. I think I'm done of
spending eight hours a day listening to the
fans on my MacBook. I do not want
to hear my fans anymore. I just want
Me too. Me too. And my editor to
run.
Hopefully nice and quiet and just focus on
the code
and just offload all of this computational heavy
stuff like building the images and node modules
and I'm
a Rust developer so I need to say
I watch Rust build times for fourteen hours
all the time. Like, you know, there are
machines that are built to do this really,
really fast, and they're not my MacBook. They're
not my local Linux machine. They're they're in
the cloud, and they're much better suited. So
Yeah. And then I love that you can
use to spin them up and where you're
like, will
automatically spin down your environments after a few
hours that they've been idle. And that's I
love that because it's like, I didn't have
to think about cleanup. I just launched my,
like, my my like this. I'm working my
application. I'm building things. When I'm done, when
I go do something else, it will spin
up spin down. I don't have to worry
about that thing being running all the time.
I don't have to worry about pulling it
up. When I'm done, just try, redeploy,
and
I'm I'm much happier that way. One less
thing to worry about. Oh, yeah. I I
I couldn't agree more.
Okay. Let's let's let's get back to our
our demo. I kinda forgot for a second.
We're actually live streaming. Oh, so so one
one more thing I wanted to to to
show you. I can show you. I prepared
a demo. We have an early I like
this. We have an integration with GitHub. Right
now, GitHub actions is actually down. I've been
looking at the status page. But if you
go to the docs, I'll I'll show you.
One of the one of the things we're
exploring here was,
now that you have your pipeline and you
have your dev environment defined in Okteto,
why you you can also take that
and use it as part of your PR
process. So if you click on the preview
environments
menu on the left
and, yeah, just go there. The idea here
is you're using the same pipeline, the same
flow as a developer, but now you're gonna
attach it to any PR. So the idea
here is I have my code. I send
a PR. GitHub will run an action. We'll
create another namespace. We'll deploy my application there.
We'll send the link to the PR,
and then anyone in your team, anyone that
you're working with,
they can now see the code, but also
see the application running with your code on
it. It's something that GitLab
does and that Heroku kinda pioneered that I
I really like. So we we brought this
into Okteto with the idea that now you
have a dev environment
and a preview environment with the same configuration,
no extra work, and and it works really
well especially with GitHub instant actions.
If you scroll down, you'll see that the
action is is very it's quite simple to
to deploy. It's just log in, create namespace,
run your pipeline,
and then get the URL back to the
to the PR.
And it's something that we use internally a
lot. Like, every time we do, like, for
instance, a change in a website,
we generate a preview environment, and then everyone
on the team can look at the website,
add comments on the text, on the looks,
on the color, on the wordiness.
Yep. And that's a cool way to involve
people on your PRs
who might not care about the code or
they might not be experts on the code,
but they are experts in the results of
your code. And that's something that we're pushing
pushing on. It works on GitHub. It works
on GitLab. We're working on integrations with Bitbucket,
with CircleCI.
It's it's just a script, so you can
Jenkins, it can work everywhere. Mhmm. But on
on GitHub, the I I really like the
actions model. It's a it's an easy way
to integrate, and then everything goes into your
repo Yep. So that everyone can look at
it and and just benefit from it. So
that's another cool thing that we're
they're kinda encouraging people to to try, see
if they like it, see if it's beneficial.
And if it is, please let us know
so we can build more of that.
Do you want to try it, or do
you do you think actions being done just
means it's not gonna work at all? It's
not gonna work right now because I think
GitHub actions yeah. It's still on green on
yellow. It's still degraded. So
I promise I I set up a report
last night. I was working on a on
a really cool demo of Compose with
GitHub actions, but it is down. But I'll
I'll share the link later on Twitter if
anybody's interested to try.
But the easiest thing is go to the
docs,
copy that action,
and you can use the movies app for
that or your own. Even even better.
Alright. Well, yeah, I'll make sure the I'll
get the URL from you. We can put
that into show notes. And when anyone watching,
not live, they can definitely check that out
and have a go at it. It's definitely
something that I'll
be keen to try it and and see
how that works. Very nice integration there.
Alright, Ramiro. Is there anything that we haven't
that you think will be interesting to show
the user before we finish up today?
Mhmm. Last last thing is
on the left, click on the developed on
Okteto
button. That is something that's my personal favorite.
So I wanna I noticed to
show it to the world. But the movies
are quite straight. So When you have a
a repo that works with Okteto, you can
add that button to anything, a read me
on GitHub,
a documentation
on your internal page.
When When you click that button,
that will automatically deploy an application on Okteto
for you.
You you just put a link to the
URL of the repo and instructions are below,
but it's it's something that
if you go to the, like, the movies
repo right now,
you can just I could yep. And so
it's just cloud.okteto.com,
and then it's got, like, a hash symbol
and a deploy with a repository that we
can take a look at. Mhmm. This part
of the story, and you can also pass
the pass the
the branch if you if you want a
specific branch. So it's something that some of
our early adopters, especially in the open source
community, are using as a way to give
their give their maintainers or contributors a one
clear experience of, like, click here and get
the application running. And And once your app
is running, then you can develop whichever one
way you want. But it's a it's a
nice way to replace, you know, like,
a long with many steps instead you qualify
it on on this on this repo on
one click, and it just runs.
Very nice. I like that feature too.
Alright. I think we've got one question, and
then we will
we'll wrap up for the day. So let's
pop it back here.
Russell is asking let me just push this
up here. Are there any Okteto features for
allowing multiple people to develop their own version
of the same service at the same time,
or is that outside the scope of what
Okteto offers?
Yes. That is that is part of the
experience. There's two ways to do that. One
is when when you show the namespaces,
every developer gets their own namespace. So you
could have you know, I can have my
my namespace with the movies app.
David has his.
And when we develop, they are completely isolated.
So you just deploy your own copy.
We're also working on a feature.
I'm gonna add this. My my dev team
might might hate me. But no. I'm kidding.
We're we're actually looking forward to to share
this with the world. We're getting a new
feature where you're gonna be able to deploy
kinda like a canonical version of your application,
let's say your integration environment,
and then you're gonna be able to develop
only specific services.
And we're gonna use a a mix of
service mesh and networking rules that let's say
the movies app. I have my API. You
have your API.
I'm gonna have a unique URL. So when
I go through my URL,
that request will hit my API.
And when you go through your URL, it's
gonna hit your API,
which for applications like the movies app make
doesn't make much sense. But if you have
a big application with twenty, thirty microservices,
some heavy infrastructure,
that'd a cool way to to interact more
like in a team layer.
Stay tuned. That will come out soon. We'll
be posting a blog post on that, but
it's it's gonna be called divert because you
divert traffic from the main to your app.
Yep. And and, yeah, definitely, team collaboration is
is an aspect that we're
very interested in in improving. That is where
we started with, like, the namespace per per
developer.
But, yeah, we're only gonna get started. So
any feedback on that, any any comments, I
would love to talk to you all. I'll
join the Discord, and we have a a
channel, Okteto, in the Kubernetes Slack.
So if you wanna talk about this later,
you wanna share your experience,
please please join us. I would love to
talk to all of you.
Awesome. Well, on that, Rumiro, I'll just say
thank you very much for joining us today
and and walking us through Okteto. It's a
really cool tool. I love the frictionless approach
to what is a really
annoying problem getting bootstrapped or started on projects
and getting productive as fast as possible. And
Okteto seems like a really cool tool that
exposes a whole bunch of features to make
that easier for people. So thank you for
your good work,
and I hope that a lot of people
watching enjoy it and will check it out
in their own time.
Rawkode, have a wonderful day. Thank you again,
and I will speak to you soon.
You, David. It was fun. Good seeing you
all. Mhmm. Bye. Bye.